[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and I heard you loud and clear on
the top 10 fact you didn't know about
Austin video and so the black clover
facts are making a comeback with the
awesome leader of the black balls who is
always taking a dump at the wrong time
Yami if you guys want to keep the black
clover fact videos coming make sure to
smash that like button to let me know
and make it a triple combo by smashing
that subscribe button and bringing that
magic youtube Bell so future black
clover videos are sent straight to your
phone let me know what fact video you
are burning up to see and you just may
see it pop up soon if you love black
clover and want to support this channel
at the same time you can now motivate
yourself to crush it in life with your
very own austere dream big work hard
t-shirt
I am extremely passionate about the idea
of chasing epic dreams and inspiring
others to work towards their dreams as
well and I feel like hasta is a
character that captures that idea
perfectly through hard work and
persistence he managed to overcome his
poor magic less background and become a
magic knight and is now working towards
his dreams of becoming the wizard king
and protecting everybody so with the
help of professional manga artist Kazuma
D we made this shirt to motivate us and
you to work hard while we move towards
our big dreams fans of anime uproar can
now get 25% off by using the code uproar
25 at checkout and without further ado
let's jump into some dark facts fact
number one speaking of dark
let's look am E's name Tabata often
tries to have the names of his
characters reflect them or their powers
in some way this is nothing new and
shown in and if you watch any of them my
hero academia fact videos you know that
horikoshi pretty much always does this
including with his main character
midoriya who has Midori aka the color
green and his name his name reflects his
green hair green eyes green hero costume
as well as the fact that he is green or
in other words a beginner when the story
starts Tabata has admitted to doing this
to accept his story doesn't take place
in Japan so he uses even more languages
in a French interview
he was asked where he got French last
names such as Klaus Loonette Tabitha
responded that he was looking for
keywords relating to the characters in
dictionaries of different languages and
he picked the ones that pleased him he
said that there are many languages in
the black clover universe so it's the
same idea as in my hero academia except
Tabata is using more than just a
Japanese language however he does also
use the Japanese language when it comes
to yami yami 'he's name reflects his
magic powers and personality yama means
dark or darkness in japanese and as we
know by now Yami has dark magic his
personality can also be dark as he's
quick to threaten people's lives
Yami's name also contains the kanji for
Knight and large obviously the knight is
another reference to darkness but we
also have large which can be seen as a
reference to its large frame since Yami
is easily one of the most Jack dudes in
the world of black clover
unlike shortstop he is also considerably
tall as well but the question remains
why does Yami have a Japanese name while
other people don't this question brings
us to fact number two Yami is from the
Japan of the black clover world although
there isn't a clover Kingdom or Diamond
Kingdom in our own world there does seem
to be a Japan in the black lower series
although it has never called Japan Yami
is said to be a foreigner from the Land
of the Rising Sun which is another way
people refer to Japan in our own world
his parents fished for a living and in
the real world Japan is famous for their
commercial fishing industry and fishing
plays an important role in the country's
history and culture as well as mentioned
Yami suka Hiro has a Japanese name but
he also has a Japanese blade a katana
which is a traditionally made Japanese
sword that was used by samurai in
ancient and feudal Japan in the Land of
the Rising Sun they speak a different
language so after he got shipwrecked and
ended up on the shores of the clover
Kingdom he had to pick up an entirely
different language but Julius helped him
out and taught him how to write in the
language of the clover Kingdom which
also happens to be similar to the
language of the Diamond Kingdom if you
pay attention there are even more
references to Yogi's Japanese origins
you can leave any other
examples you can think of in the
comments below fact number three Yami is
actually based on a real-life person in
the Austin V do I explained that the
black clover creator and everyone who's
met him will tell you that he's exactly
like Austin so it makes sense that Yami
asked us captain and mentor would be
based on one of Tabitha's own mentors
and it turns out he actually was
aspiring mangakas or manga artists often
start out with assisting more
established mangakas when asked about
how many assistants he has tabatha
explained that he had six and that the
person who inspired him to create Yami
was a mangaka he assisted himself he
said he appreciates the experience he
gained from being an assistant and how
it helped him get to where he is today
the inspiration for Yami appears to be
toshiaki washiro the author of siren a
series that got 16 volumes Tabata
assisted Yoshida and out of everyone
that could have possibly been included
in volume one of the black clover manga
cover that included a crossover manga at
the end that he made with his mentor it
was a crossover between black Laura and
yoshi rosemon kaga Megami which was then
running in Shonen Jump but has since
been discontinued ironically in the
manga yoshi Rose characters actually
joining the black Bulls while in reality
it was Tabata who joined us heroes team
when he first came to Tokyo in the
afterword tabata even says they got
married and his mentor his Yami was the
guest of honor at the ceremony and he
read a wonderful speech for tavataan his
wife he goes on to say that he will
forever be in his debt and no matter how
much he'll thank him it will never be
enough and he's right that he owes us
Shiro a lot and we do as well because
not only did he show Tabitha the ropes
of the manga world he also inspired one
of the baddest and most popular
characters in black clover which brings
us to fact number four let's discuss
Yami's popularity in the first two
Japanese popularity polls Yami got
second place only losing out to the MC
himself the big dreaming hard-working
hasta however the popularity poll
results were different in the West in
the to visiting polls Yami actually got
first place in both even beating out the
protagonist
this is a huge feat which should
definitely not be sneezed at the
life-threatening wrong time dumping
captain of the black bulls managed to
get first place in a world that's filled
with awesome characters like MC hasta
best girl Noel epic firebender who
goalie on and so on there's no doubt
about it Yami is extremely popular
everywhere but let me know what you
think he's even more popular in the West
than auste fact number five next let's
look at some of the super fun rankings
that are included as bonus material in
the manga volumes and how Yami fared in
them in terms of physical strength out
of everyone in the world of black clover
Yami came in first place Austin the
character who devoted so much time to
physical training to compensate for his
lack of magic even ranked lower than
Yami so he's definitely got the bronze
now let's turn to intelligence he ranked
tenth most intelligent when it came to
magic Knight captains you may be
thinking how is he so stupid that he
came in 10th out of 9 captains but this
list actually included the new purple
orchid captain and the acting crimson
lion captain so he didn't even come in
last he came in second last beating out
Jack the Ripper keep in mind though
captain's tend to be extremely
intelligent so we can get a better sense
of Yami's brains if we look at his
intelligence compared to the other black
bulls in this case he came in sixth
place while our MC hasta came in last at
11th place however as we all know not
giving up in surpassing your limits is
always more powerful than intelligence
so this doesn't hurt either of them too
much in battle Yami is also the 5th best
character at handling his liquor and
although he didn't rank in the top five
for best looking male characters in the
series it is noteworthy that the number
one most beautiful female in the world
of black clover which is Charlotte
according to the manga creator has an
undying crush on our boy Yami fact
number 6 for this fact let's go over
Yami statistics according to the data
book he scored a perfect 5 out of 5 in
physical strength
a 5 out of 5 in magic amount a 4 out of
5 in magic control a 4 out of 5 in magic
sensing a 4 out of 5 in cleverness
his customized category was limit
surpassing and you can bet he scored a
perfect five out of five in that to be
honest I mean surprise didn't score six
out of five in the category but it's
crazy to think about the fact that Yami
is even stronger than hasta except
instead of having no magic he has a 5
out of 5 in magic amount he's like the
best of both worlds throw in his ability
to surpass his limits when the situation
calls for it and you have easily one of
the strongest mages in the entire series
let me know who you think is the
strongest mage in black clover in the
comment section below
fact number seven Yami was initially
gonna be as jacked as he is now although
he was always planned to be the baddest
captain ever his initial sketch reveals
that he was originally gonna be a bit
leaner and that his height was gonna be
176 centimeters or 5 foot 9 inches
obviously he ended up being the
physically strongest person in the black
clover world that we met so far so his
design got bulkier to reflect that and
his height ended up being 183
centimeters in other words he is over 6
feet tall along with physical strength
and magical amount he is even
impressively tall for anime especially
compared to short stuff who is only 155
centimeters tall or 5 foot 1 Yami's
definitely got a lot going for him
fact number 8 Yami's japanese voice
actors a 46 year old Junichi Suwabe he
won Best Supporting Actor Award in the
7th seiyu Awards he played the emcee
takashi kimura in high school of the
dead and the exceptionally talented
Daiki al-amin a in Kuroko no basket to
name a few of his older roles
more recently fans of the channel may
also like to know that he actually
voiced the other awesome and dark show
and mentor from my hero academia shota
Aizawa this actually makes so much sense
I am not at all surprised to figure this
out because Yami and Aizawa definitely
give off a similar vibe some of the lee
sin's fans should know that Junichi even
made an appearance in that series as
bonds mentor and father figures Avago
long story short Junichi has been
killing it for like two deck
at this point voicing many characters
from popular anime and with ongoing
roles like Aizawa and Yami it seems like
he'll be around for a good while to come
back number nine Yami's English version
is voiced by the forty-five year old
Christopher Robin sabot Christopher is a
legend in his own right and he has been
active in anime for about as long as
Junichi has he has done many iconic
roles like Vegeta and piccolo and Dragon
Ball Zorro in one piece and even the
other great mentor in my hero academia
all might himself there's no doubt that
Yami is in good hands with these two
guys but let me know if you personally
prefer one version of Yami over the
other in the comments back number 10
alright we have arrived to the legendary
fact number 10 which if you've watched
these videos you know is not just one
fact but a kind of lightning round of as
many facts as I can mention in a short
period of time the name of this round
usually changes depending on the
character I'm covering so rather than
calling this the lightning round let's
double the limit surpassing round
let's surpass our tenth fact limit in
three two one less Jam Yami has also
been called the destruction God or in
other words the god of destruction so he
shares the title with other insanely
powerful anime entities like the
colossal titan and beerus sama Yami is
28 years old and he was born on
September 17th making him a Virgo
he likes cigarettes so he joined spikes
on G Onizuka and other anime characters
who make smoking look way too cool he
also likes intimidation interesting
people which is why the black balls are
probably the most interesting group of
misfits ever
Yami's grimoire is the background for
the fifth volume of black clover and his
face is on the spine of the sixth volume
Yami used to be part of the azure deer
squad along with william van gence under
julius when it comes to fights he has
either one got a draw or been
interrupted every time so he doesn't
actually have a loss to his name yet
there was also a rare sketch in the
manga where tabitha drew Yami and you
know together an unlikely pair as he
notes lastly his blood type is O as an
OMG Yami is the baddest and that is it
for today's video thank you so much for
watching and if you
enjoyed this video make sure to pick up
the closest katana and use dimensions
slash on that like button and if you
haven't don't forget to smash that
subscribe on and ring that magic YouTube
Bell so the lady loving Finn raw can
teleport future black clover videos
straight to your phone as soon as they
come out if you want to help decide what
videos I make in the future make sure
the suggested character you are really
passionate about seeing next in the
comments if you want a rock awesome
black clover merge that will motivate
you to hustle and support more content
like this at the same time then
definitely check out our offs to dream
big work hard shirt at anime up Broadcom
the link in the description and remember
to use the code uproar 25 to get 25% off
your purchase thank you for your support
it means the world to me and until next
time see a space cowboy
[Music]
you